bienvenue sur diagonale tv pour suivre
la fin de ces huitièmes de finale du
championnat du monde féminin 2015
huitièmes de finale qui pour marie sebag
vont se terminer donc par ce tie-break
tie break face à natalia pogo nina
malheureusement mari n'a pas réussi à
consolider son avantage qu'elle avait
pris en première partie il s'est fait
donc remonter au score
tie break pour départager les joueuses
alors deux parties rapides et puis en
cas d'égalité mais sur les blitz de
départage alors c'est parti pour marie
c'est bagdad
les blancs et qui démarre avec ce qui
est attendu de 4 puisque la jouer tout
le long du tournoi
tout le long de ces championnats pour
l'instant cette ouverture donc le sec
bon très bien pour une image ou la même
cave et f3 cavale et ses 6 marie répète
fou b5 et on a droit à de nouveau à la
fameuse défense de berlin donc on
commentera assez rapidement la partie et
on va pas rentrer dans trop de détails
c'est des parties rapides
donc on va juste noter les points
cruciaux qui vont apparaître au fil des
coûts donc ouverture de berlin défense
de berlin détroit donc la marie répète
la même partie la même façon d'éviter la
grande variantes
on a déjà parlé donc je reviendrai pas
dessus tout c'est simple petit rock dès
6 ans très solide
h3 évite un clouage ici on g4
petit rock aussi hélas mari prend à ses
6 pourquoi pas donc pour casser la
structure noir c'est une autre façon de
jouer mais prend tour à 1 tour 8
cavaliers en d2 cavaliers 17 pour les
noirs ça c'est un coût original qu'on
peut nathan ducale et 17 alors c'est
peut-être pour jouer cavalier fuite
suivi de f5 avec le fou ici contre
lacazette 5 peut-être essayer de faire
une rupture au centre les foules et noir
ont été ré de libérer le casser la
structure de piolenc de faim de d'ouvrir
le jeu voilà pour que leur père de fou
un jour dont le père de fou mais un
position étant fermé pour l'instant
c'est c'est pas c'est pas forcément un
avantage dans cette position là cavalier
c4 très bien alors à noter que ce
cavalier
on me fait un petit peu pression sur eux
c'est un bon ça c'est un détail je pense
dans la position
bon les noirs peuvent pas jouer des
scènes puisqu'il y aurait prises ayant
fait quand même trois pièces sur sur
cinq mais aussi ce cavalier empêche le
fait empêche contrôler la casse b6 donc
si le four reculons pour aller changer
et donc il y aura plus de paires de fou
ce qui à long terme pourrait s'avérer
pénible b6 alors les noirs mettre tout
de suite leurs foins b6 invitant les
blancs à prendre et dans ce cas je prend
du plomb à ce qui ramène un pion vers le
centre donc très intéressant ce que fait
marie d'abord à 4-4 menace à 5
et puis le fou risque d'être pris parce
qu'il vient c5 ces trois b 4 avec une
avancée de pions blancs ce n'est pas
forcément agréable donc les noirs
répondent par à 5 mais en jouant à 5
on peut plus reprendre maintenant b6 du
point et donc mari prend maintenant le
fou hélas les noirs vont quand même des
clous et alors leur faim des clowns des
doubler leurs prix ont doublé à des
puces double ici c'est jamais agréable
un des pions doublé
en défense c'est souvent très fort mais
c'est pas très mobile non simplement des
doubles et voilà et maintenant on a nos
pions qui sont tous liés voilà on a
rétabli une structure de pions normale
après ces échanges dont la position
s'est aplani faut pas dire que les
blancs et pour l'instant est sorti de
l'ouverture sur sorties l'ouverture avec
un avantage des quatre alors la peau
goni naoui joue un cou tendu ces 5
pourquoi pas on s'est un peu tendue ces
cinq bassins vite les blancs à se
décider soit prenant cinq fois pendant
ces 5 alors peut-être que les bains
aurait pu jouer ces 3 1 pour regarder la
pression simplement mais quoi faire
après c'est ça le problème c'est pas
évident dans cette position de trouver
des compromis blanc de trouver des plans
surtout un bon mari vous sans doute ce
cas mieux elle prend 1,5 cavale et prend
prend même pas du pion on prend du
cavalier on garde la colonne ouverte
éventuellement sur le pion aux quatre
donc on peut jouer fou bessette et on
oblige les blancs à se défendre puisque
quatre attaques et si on arrive à forcer
les blancs même à jouer 3 bat on
affaiblit un tout petit peu loin blanc
s'est jamais agréable de ce jeu ce genre
de coups donc la mari décide de rentrer
dans la finale carrément cavaliers prend
puis on prend maintenant semble logique
et simplement
elle aurait pu ici échanger les dames et
puis finalement se contenter du nul
c'est dans une position finalement très
symétriques je pense qu'il a pas de
grand danger ici mais il m'arrive de
jouer pour le ghana donc elle joue
l'intéressant damage 5 montrait bien
dommage c'est bon je fais une pression
sur le rock avec une petite idée on va
voir tour à cette très jolie les noirs
se disent banque est la meilleure place
pour ce fou finalement oui contre les
cases intéressante on sait jamais ce que
les blancs veulent jouer sur cette
diagonale il pourra peut-être plus tard
venir en bessette
mais en attendant il est bien placé
assez vite voilà donc on n'a pas décidé
parce qu'en baisse est bon il va taper
sur 4 mais s'est bien défendue donc y'a
pas d'autres pièces qui peut aider en
jouant tour à sète on permet de jouer
tour baisse dont 17
on peut venir en d4 chatouiller le pion
aux quatre foulées cette dame à 8 et on
a une pression maximale sur quatre c'est
une possibilité donc tour à sept coups
malin c'est parfois un moyen de
développer la tour comme ça faut y
penser quand la septième est libéré même
pour les noirs c'est bien de mettre en
septième et en plus on peut doubler sur
la colonne des donc marie continue son
plan dont c'est intéressant elle aussi
regarder elle profite du fait que la
troisième rangée libéré vous retour à
troyes et de venir essayer de
chatouiller l'alleud
l'europe noir tour 17
maintenant le problème quand même c'est
que les noirs ont un très très bon
contrôle de la colonne des bons ils
peuvent pas venir en d1 puisque la dame
protéger il adam un oeil ici sur la case
d1
donc il n'ya pas de tour et dames ça
protège bien pour l'instant ça va
toucher 3 alors attention il peut se
passer des trucs on peut avoir des idées
des d'échec pourquoi pas carrément de
prise de la tour 1 ça peut arriver parce
que fait le roi ainsi laura viande g7
damage 6 suivi de fous j'ai cinq
attaques la dame n'a ce fou et 6 avec un
quasi match ça peut être très très vite
très dangereux
donc attention mais les noirs ne panique
pas très jolis coups de défense
tranquille tour des six bateaux
réussissent parce qu'on veut garder le
tout sans doute le case pour le fou tour
des six jeux contrôler la 6e donc je
peux par exemple simplement avec ma tour
je pourrais défendre en venant angers 6
s'il ya besoin
j'évite de m'affaiblir à j'évite de les
noirs les blancs aussi haut pour rejouer
fois-ci savez j'ai six forcé mais là
simplement sur imaginons un x 6 ça
marche pas simplement les noirs
répondent probablement le meilleur c'est
tout rejet 6 voilà tout est protégé et
tout et tout et aussi en prison donc
c'est pas facile là pour le bien de
trouver un coup le mieux ici sans doute
c'est de revenir en d3 attaque la dame
mais finalement c'est les noirs qui ont
mis leur tour face au roi blanc voyez ça
elle verse sa révérence la manoeuvre
donc c'est pas une bonne idée
il faut venir la porte à clé parce que
sinon on a on a une deuxième pièce
attaquer mais là on joue autour des 3
pour le temps de sortir le faux bond
les blancs ne tombe pas dans ce piège
simplement b3 alors b3 c'est quoi l'idée
sans doute simplement protégé à 4 éviter
des manoeuvres ou à la fin le pion à 4
et est perdue là ses pions se contrôle
bien les uns les autres
il n'y a pas de problème bon la position
est quand même très équilibrée même si
il faut faire attention puisque les
foudres couleurs opposées peuvent être
des thèmes d'attac autant en finale
c'est un facteur 2 nuls autant tant que
c'est pas la finale c'est un facteur de
justement d'attac parce que c'est
difficile de pour les noirs par exemple
de contrôler gaze noire et inversement
pour les blancs les cases blanches
même si bon on le voit avec tours g6 les
noirs risque pas grand chose en position
est très équilibré et a foulé cette
simple idée qu'on avait dit tout à
l'heure on commence à chatouiller ce
pion là ça va être un problème pour
marier on va voir fouler sec attaque la
dame on peut pas aller trop peut pas
faire un peu trop n'importe quoi faut il
faut peut-être éviter des coups comme f6
parce que si on joue le pion f6 bombay
on affaiblit un peu la diagonale là
celle-là sur le roi bon repas très très
grave je pense mais c'est jamais
agréable quand même on s'affaiblit un
tout petit peu le rock bon c'était quand
même jouable mais ça paraît pas très bon
donc les noirs simplement levitte dame
j'évite au maximum l'affaiblir le rock
tant qu'ils y sont pas forcés et à
murray continue son idée un bon ceci dit
c'est cohérent c'est bien h4 voilà alors
h4 belle idée je vais peut-être poussé
h56 et je veut affaiblir l'europe je
veux que les noirs soit obligée de jouer
ses 6 avec un rock faible en roi qui
sera toujours sous la menace d'un mac du
couloir ou de de se faire déloger à long
terme et parfois faut jouer des plans à
long terme donc la 3e suite les noirs se
disent bon pourquoi pas je mets le roi
maintenant j'en enlève toute possibilité
pour les blancs d'oeufs
de me coller des y avait quand même
aussi ici la menace fois ci c'était
possible parce que surtout reprendre
dans prend la tour clou le pion non mais
on ne rejoue étrangers 6 on l'a déjà dit
en jouant h 4 g menace h5 et c'est pas
pareil c'est pas la même roux a ensuite
mal à la dame f3 attaque un petit peu le
pion à vii petit oeil sur le pion à vii
et nombreux un coup sans doute au coude
attente un tour en fuite
à toi pas facile pour les blancs la
position qu'un très équilibré ya pas de
vraie faiblesse du côté noir ils ont
essayé au regard des mails et noir ont
ont été malins et wifi justement éviter
toute tentation de pousser les pions
ce qui est toujours un affaiblissement
possible dans me2 kikoo avec peut-être
un petit piège des petits pièges s'il
faut faire attention bon pour l'instant
il ya un an voit pas trop mais tour des
quatre alors on l'avait dit tout à
l'heure ils font maintenant la tournée
chatouiller donc la menace de gagner un
pion et surtout le pion b4 la fin le
piano 4 mains de marie quasiment obligé
de jouer je travaille a pas beaucoup
trop f3 bon eh bien là c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour les blancs parce
que la taxe sur le roc a pas réussi la
dame n'est pas prête de revenir de ce
côté là donc et touré four pas trop
comment on va attaquer bon le fou pour
revenir un jeu assez vite selon eux
trois ils attaquent la tour même en c1
b2 bon il peut revenir vite met à
tourner à leur jeu 7 tours ça c'est
quand même très embêtant parce que
comment elle va revenir en jeu on peut
imaginer tour h3 rêve de tout rachat est
d'essayer de faire des échanges en d1
bon les blancs historiens quand même
impasse que le fou contrôle très bien la
casse des deux donc les noirs pourront
pas à pénétrer dans le camp blanc sauf à
proposer des échanges en d1 et encore on
voit pas trop comment il faudrait jouer
f6 me joue
le fou bouger puidoux triplé ici avant
que les blancs réussissent à mettre les
trois pièces lourdes en bas mais là les
blancs aurait dû essayer sans doute de
consolider bon tout cas c'est au nord de
joueurs bref trois tours décision là on
revient en défense et on a forcé les
blancs a joué trois voiliers tout à
l'heure on voulait on aurait bien aimé
que les noirs juifs 6 s'est laissé les
banques se sont un tout petit peu
affaibli là il peut y avoir un jour un
échec ici maintenant un tout petit peu
pénible
voilà bon c'est pas très très grave en a
[ __ ] case noire s'est pas encore
décisif c'est facile one est décisif
dans la tour des huit bon très bien eva
marie choisi sans doute mauvais plan
parce que là roi f2 alors si tour d un
sa menace rien simplement tour h3 en cas
de prise prix d'un prend et puis ça y'a
rien quoi pour les noirs on peut pas
vraiment au point fr en fait voilà donc
après je reviens et à un achat et il se
passe rien
un parti sera probablement très
probablement nulle et la marijuana h 2
bon moi j'aime pas trop parce que la
tour en là elle n'est pas prête de
revenir je l aurais bon c'est sûr mis au
tapis 6 mai à les blancs n'ont pas de
moyens de venir ajouter de la pression
maintenant ils ont raté leurs attaques
enfin en tout cas les noirs c'est plutôt
et noir qui ont bien défendu sans
craquer sans cesse à s'affaiblir et les
noms en profitent maintenant tour d un
si on avait joué le roi en f2 on pouvait
jouer tour h3 ici avec l'idée simplement
tour h1 et puis soit la tour revient
soyez des échanges et on rentre en
finale sans problème
tout reprend d'apprendre
hélas déjà c'est délicat de d'échangés
parce que j'échange tout reprend la
tourette active a peut-être essayé de
venir en b1 b2 et les blancs pas le
temps de revenir avec le retour qui est
mal placée voyez le problème alors que
bon si le roi était humble en échange
tout puis on va on va y arriver quand on
n'échange pas d'un entourage trois nanas
c'est au tour h1n1 comme on l'avait dit
tout à l'heure simplement voilà bon donc
là bon mari aurait pu jouer aussi à
notre un coup intéressant quand même ici
c'est dan b5 attaques des six que font
les noirs par ci et noir jouent d'un v6
ça c'est possible
il ya un très joli coup des blancs est
intéressant c'est que b4 alors pourquoi
mais ce pion est prêt et clouées sur la
dame puisqu'elle fou derrière en jouant
b4 je peux pousser à quatre ou six les
noirs prennent à un bep 4g faut prendre
des six attaques la tour et le pion à 5
tombe aussi donc je mens 2 gagne un pion
et si les noirs prennent en b 4 est-ce
que je jouais cinq et je vais gagner le
pion b6 le pion c5 va rester faible est
bon alors c'est sûr j'ai la tour par
contre qui un peu envie toujours là ça
c'est une erreur je pense stratégie au
lieu de quoi la ici donc mari change pas
c'est la tour se réactive est pas là pas
la sienne et non pas pas comment leur
vie en jeu alors quand je me fais tout
simplement
donc elle joue elle aurait pu jouer 25
et au caté quand même pas mal ajout dame
ces dames c4 pourquoi pour garder un
oeil sur ces 2 et ne pas permettre au
noir de s'infiltrer trop trop loin bon
les noirs font attention puisque
attention là le pion 17 est attaqué qui
plus est si je joue tour 17 pour le
protéger
jaffe bima 8e donc il peut y avoir des
thèmes si je joue au roi g8 c'est
possible - g8
pendant que j'ai encore mes dames 17
rebonds et noir carrément décidé de
revenir alors acheté menace c'est
toujours l'idée de marie menace h6 et
affaibli le rock mais simplement h6 je
bloque la progression est finalement ce
tueur est faible maintenant s option est
faible donc oui c'est cette attaque elle
est quand même peu voilà marche pas quoi
donc défense des noirs craque pas et à
ce moment là marie fait une gaffe on est
au 30e coup alors là encore beaucoup
dépensé dans l est un peu moins bien
autant très nettement et la haye le joug
belge ou f4 leur f4 c'est une faute
c'est une grosse faute puisque la ikos
une combinaison quasiment forcé comprend
attaques de pièces fo prend mari devait
se dire bunge active
j'essaie d'ouvrir le jeu pour mon fou
pour attaquer ce rock mais en fait c'est
aura blanquer faible c'est pas le roi
noir
regardez combien des troubles maintenant
qu'on a poussé 1,5 à des échecs qui
peuvent venir on peut même prendre le
pion sur échec le fou table sur la
diagonale maintenant que le pion aux 4
malheureusement
maintenant il il est tout seul quoi il
est plus protégé
donc ça devienne faiblesse et si on est
obligé d'avancer pour pas le perdre ce
fou tape sur le roi aussi on fait les
blancs se trompe c'est eux qui donnent
ici du jeu au noir et ça va aller très
vite en regard des dames cette attaque à
la fois eu 4 et menace d'un match car
échec gagne le fief 4 et en plus que
marie sans doute pas vu c'est que la
tour des huit viande et quatre attaques
la dame et le pion aux 4 donc ça c'est
une erreur tactique de marie qui doit
être aussi fatigué en un tie-break ses
briques aussi qu on est en huitièmes de
finale ça fait quand même séjourné au
troisième tour elle a joué quand même
bon nombre de partis langue là ça fait 6
plus là déjà joué un tie break bon bref
c'est vrai que c'est pas facile donc la
fatigue doit jouer ici donc là ah bon
marié le moindre mal elle essaye sais
pas trop quoi faire parce que le mieux
ici en fait sans doute c'était d'enlever
le fou enlève le fou comme ça sur échecs
ont fait tour et on perd que le pion aux
4 c'est quand même catastrophique
on va se prendre une grosse attaque et
noir sont sans doute déjà gagnante mais
on peut encore essayer de tenir le haut
lieu de quoi à marie craque complètement
effet au 5 simplement tour des quatre
ans l'attend encore floues g5 en
espérant je sais pas quoi d'ailleurs
sans doute autour prend vous prend ce
qui serait très bien mais non les noirs
se trompent pas ils prennent le foot
simplement la dame continue d'être
attaqué les noirs sont gagnants ils ont
une pièce de plus le roi blanc est
complètement en l'air ici a faibli tout
seul
et elle perd donc cette première manche
le mari voilà donc là c'est pas bon tie
break ceci lycée les parties rapides
donc tout peut tout peut changer assez
rapidement il suffit de gagner la
seconde voilà il suffit de gagner la
seconde partie et après de tenter en
beach où il peut se passer n'importe
quoi voilà alors c'est décevant
puisqu'elle était pas loin de pouvoir se
qualifier on a vu avait gagné quand même
la première partie longue elle se fait
remonter et puis là donc elle perd ça
promet cette première partie presque en
vendangeant sa position un peu tout seul
peut-être c'est la fatigue on va dire
que c'est ça et peut-être le dira à son
retour de russie
elle expliquera tout ça donc on va voir
la deuxième partie donc marie cette fois
allé noir ça va être ça va être dur mais
c'est des parties rapides donc il peut
se passer n'importe quoi donc ces partis
des quatre cas les 6
ces quatre ans la marine nous avait
habitués à des 5 c 6 avec une hausse
lave mais là elle joue e6 voilà donc
alors elle aurait pu tenter ces six pour
jouer toujours une slam mais longue
saucisse donc là on va jouer qu'à liège
3 b 6 donc on va avoir une fameuse
ninkovic est un où le west end yens
c'est un peu pareil bon voilà on sort le
fou souvent des quatre si on si les
blanches aux cavaliers c3 et le fou à
venir en 17
avec l'aide du cavalier on contrôle très
bien la case de quatre mois là elle
change d'ici
marie-chantal verture puisqu'elle
s'était quand même fait dominer on l'a
vu dans dans la partie retour sur la
slave donc elle a décidé de changer
j'ai trois fois 6 attaque le pion c4 b3
foulée quatre échecs ou des deux et on
revient de 7 ses classiques
l'idée c'est que les noirs considère que
le fou en d2 est mal placé parce que la
dame ne contrôle pas des quatre et que
ce fou s'il reste en détention il devra
rejouer donc c'est pas finalement il est
mal placé ou g2a l'attention parce qu'on
a un fou qui vise quand même la tour à 8
je peux revenir bien sûr en baisse est
avec le fou mais ça me fait peur dans le
temps parce que je veux fois ci si c'est
pour venir c'est pas c'est pas terrible
donc là l'idée séduit ce mois la c6 très
bien on bouche à damier bonal grâce aux
pions
voilà le pion empêche le fou d'aller
plus loin et en même temps on prépare la
poussée des cinq des noirs qui va
rajouter de la pression sur ce fameux
pions ses quatre petits rock des scènes
voilà ça y est c'est leur pression sur
ces quatre d'un de ces deux souple à
noter que sur un coup comme cavale et c3
eh bien ces quatre étant prises prise
prise fou prend voilà attention il ya
quand même des menaces que le câble y
vient aux cinq attaques le fou le pion
c6 est attaquée avec le fou qui a
derrière s'échouer par des tout ça petit
rock tour d un toujours ce fameux dans
toutes ses variantes on a vu à chaque
fois le fameux vis-à-vis penny le tour
d'aman cas des changes à la fin la dame
peut être en prise et ça c'est pas bon
pour bien placer en d1 dans ces types de
variantes on l'a vu plein de fois
cavalli 17 à 4 allée blanche très très
bien ce début pas de faute à quatre et
bien l'idée c'est de jouer à 5 forcer
les noirs peut être à jouer bessec
voilà avec un fou qui bouchent sa propre
diagonale et les maris joue un bon coup
sans doute un coup qui donne
d'excellentes chances de
pour jouer pour le gain cavalier e 4 ça
complique avec l'idée souvent de jouer
f5
ça complique la position avec car elle
est très bien défendu 1,4 mais ça
affaiblit un peu les cases noires mais
ça complique fouet 3 on laisse pas les
noirs en prend dans la paire de fou f5
voilà posit cavaliers très très bien
bien tenu des cases noires sont faibles
par contre voilà forcément on peut pas
tout avoir
cavale et c3 maintenant donc là les
blancs n'ont pas peur de la manoeuvre
qui aurait pu avoir lieu ici puis on
prend ces quatre ans qu'il est possible
et simplement ici belle et blanc
prennent en quatre
une pièce et si on prend b3 enfin cela
ne s'apprend une pièce si on prend en b3
intermédiaire ça doit pas marcher
puisque on reprend de la dame ici et
regardez hop on dise aux six avec échec
donc là si les noirs prennent simplement
en quatre et bien je peux prendre en 4 6
et si on prend des 3
simplement je ramasse tout avec échec la
suite dame prend b3 et y'a pas de
problème même jeu même mieux j'ai un
pion de plus j'ai gagné un point ou
passage donc là c'est pas moi il faut
pas jouer ça donc tout ça parce que
évidemment tout ça s'affaiblit donc faux
3f cents qu'avaient laissé 3 si on prend
là on affaiblit les cases blanches
voilà ici c'est solide à condition de
pas bouger pour ses 8 alors nous aussi
on est un vis-à-vis tour dames voilà ça
c'est bien
c'est solide 1 les noirs sont son bien
je pense que la norme très bien joué le
début aura déjà aucun échange de fait
donc les possibilités de gains pour les
noirs sont maximales et problème la
position est équilibrée ici dans le b2
très subtil dame b2 j'enlève le
vis-à-vis
la dame est toujours bien placé food et
cavalli prof 4 maintenant pour les
blancs qui ont l'air de très bien
connaître ces deux variantes avec les
idées câblée prendre quatre sa force
quasiment la suite f34 et la cavaille 5
voilà la dame étant venus en b2 on
contrôle le 5
donc en cas de prise je peux reprendre
du pian et le fameux vis-à-vis tour
dames peut s'avérer pénible à la fin bon
voilà cabrio sec
donc là on peut envisager plein de coups
pour les noirs mari choisit le coup qui
gardent le maximum de pièces sur
l'échiquier certainement 4e 6 pas
forcément le meilleur coup mais on est
en partie rapide bon c'est quand même
beaucoup bien sûr ça consolide les
classes blanche saverne des pièces mari
joue pour le gain le temps va jouer
beaucoup dans cette partie et de
joueuses vont se retrouver et note
fourrage 3 alors magnifique un an faut
connaître cette ouverture mais c'est
beau à regarder
voilà maintenant que le pion f a pris
mais forcément la case ou cissé fait
donc vu que le foot ap contre mur ici là
il va chercher le petit point faible
voilà et ça oblige les noirs à mettre
une pièce en défense de ce pion et noir
trouvent rien mieux que de le défendre
par l'adam bon très bien mais la dame
est un peu immobilisé la défense du pion
garder un fond j'avais oublié ce type 2
comme ça de de défense hélas les blancs
on profite maintenant à cinq par la
menace à prendre v6 et la torah se
libère attaquant le fou éventuellement
ou si le fougueux 17 on va pouvoir venir
en a 7 et 1 active
cette tour qui pour l'instant n'était
pas à petit donc les noirs refuse
d'ouvrir la colonne des scènes très bien
magnifiquement joué hélas les blancs en
l'air de très bien connaître cette
position ils prennent des 500 problème
marie a plusieurs possibilités
on peut pas reprendre du pillon enfin on
peut mais dans ce cas là on perd la
qualité cause du fou donc on pourrait
reprendre du pied on sait c'est une
possibilité mais si on reprend nos
espions
c'est prendre des 5
simplement les blancs jour et très
certainement tour des c1 puisque
maintenant vu tout ça est bouché la tour
a plus rien à faire là où l'autre tour
m'amuse plus tout cela et voilà on
commence à jouer sur la colonne c'est
comme le pion aux six est faible ça va
pas être facile pour les noirs de
contester la colonne en faisant fou
prend échec en plus on contre on attaque
réac assez vite donc sans doute là les
blancs saurez tout peut-être un peu
mieux positionner la mauricie donc marie
prendre du cavalier alors c'est pas mal
mais ce pion aux quatre maintenant il
commanda part au prix d'un pion il sera
tout seul il est isolé isolé donc il va
être perdus mais les noms ne vous suit
et s'activer tout à fait intéressante
parce que tôt ou tard on va pouvoir
jouer ce pion en d4
ce pion en b 4 va te contrôler la casse
ces trois ça va libérer l'action du fou
qui plus est sur deux donc par exemple
en cas d'un match 5 bon pas là parce qu'
il faudrait de protéger au 6 mai on
pourrait attaquer à la fois le fou et le
pian 2 avec l'aide du x 6 et en plus si
on contrôle c3 avec b4 on a le cavalier
qui vient ans ces trois attaques que 2
et la tour d un voyez donc en fait en
lâchant presque ce pion aux 4 on se
donne des possibilités qui toi siens et
la falaise sans doute joué b4 ici
des 4 6 avec l'idée est simplement
qu'avait laissé trois attaques latour
attaques de avec le fou et c'est pas
facile pour les bains de trouver une
solution parce que si je joue food et
deux pour empêcher le carrier de mener
en c3 et bien et je perds le pion aux
deux et ça c'est un pion important c'est
les pions en plein centre qui plus est
une fois que deux a disparu avec le fou
je peux venir en d3 ou un f3 et le pion
aux 4 et protégés bon alors fou j'ai
deux on est comme les blancs ont fini
leur travail
le pion aux 4 s'est affaiblie donc ils
vont le prendre
kabylie et 6 alors revient à m6 alors on
pouvait quand même joué ici b4 encore
laïcité avec la justice il puisque
maintenant si fou prend le 4 qui reste
possible
simplement on peut alors on peut prendre
on peut jouer qu'à laisser 3 à leurs
biens ou prendre mais pas jouer qu'à
laisser 3 c'est pas mal
simplement attaque le fou et l'atome
voilà on s'en doute les blancs dans ce
cas-là donnerait la qualité c'est sans
doute prévu et simplement je reprends et
j'ai pris le pion aux quatre plus le
pion b donc j'ai deux pions pour la
qualité c'est bien ça suffit enjoué par
le pion de quand même ici en plus voilà
une position intéressante mais la paire
de fou le pion de plus sans doute que
les blancs sont pas plus mal c'est la
qualité et peut être pas si importante
ici donc cavalier 6 issifou g2 la marine
joue pas c'est de rendre qui quand elles
simplifient et et une position très
difficile à gagner il faut pas oublier
que marie joue pour gagner donc qu'il
faut qu'elle garde un maximum de
pression le plus longtemps possible dans
la partie en espérant une faute pour
l'instant les blancs font aucune faute
donc là h3 bon pourquoi pas je prends un
petit coup mais aussi bon il faut jouer
la pendule attention les deux joueuses
aussi c'est les parties rapides comment
ça va plus avoir beaucoup de temps il
que 10 secondes
raju pas parcourt les quatre de la part
des noirs rien le joue maintenant
non mais c'est toujours bien parce que
le fou à 6 et baya est actif alors
qu'ils n'étaient pas plus b4 et très
bien protégé par le par les fous
plus tard on pourra peut-être envisager
des c5 avec la tour le fou des six
essayer de casser le centre blanc c'est
des possibilités alors pas tout de suite
tout est bien protégé de la part des
nord la dame protège le cavaly par
transparence donc on peut prendre du
pillon bon mais c'est des possibilités
pour pour plus tard dam des deux les
blancs quand même jeu
toujours agréable sans faiblesse n'y a
pas de faiblesse côté blanc tombé 5 fu
b5
c'est un coup tranquille qui en crise de
temps est agréable à jouer ça consolide
la position je consolide à la fois ces
six et puis aussi je donne aux fous une
protection n'est pas en l'air alors
quand à 6 ils étaient quand même emprise
ce n'était pas facile à aller chercher
on assiste donc avait laissé quatre bons
attaque le fou des six ou sept garde un
oeil sur bien sûr le pion p 4 x 4 des
blancs maintenant que le fou a fini son
travail il se met maintenant sur cette
diagonale est une menace possible bien
sûr c'est de le caler les six attaques
dame tour sur fou prend fou prend
attaque la tour et le pion b4 qui
tombera donc attention il faut faire
quelque chose
cavaliers des 5 ça c'est une possibilité
pourquoi pas
attaque le fouet f4 bon et alors est ce
que les blancs peuvent jouer quand même
ici cavaliers des six tu as l'air bon ça
marche pas sans doute à cause de fou
prend simplement comprend et maintenant
ah oui les noirs ont tous coups
magnifiques ici je vous laisse chercher
superbe pas facile à voir je sais pas ce
que maria vie je sais pas regardez je
vous le fais quand même
pouf tour preuve de presse le coup
surprenant le cook auquel on ne s'attend
pas tout reprend f2 qui casse le rock et
si le roi bien sûr prends ça serait une
faute énorme puisque simplement e3 le
cavalier protège et ils fourchette royal
vous voyez à la fin il ya une pointe la
terrible qu'elle ait des cinq les noirs
attendent que ça que les blancs joue
cavalier des six prises prise tour en f2
avec là c'est plus la même partie parce
que le roi s'affaiblit la taureau f2
devient et quand un terrible
il peut se passer beaucoup de choses ça
fait ça fait un peu peur donc les blancs
sans doute le voit plus ou moins
puisqu'ils jouaient 3oh 3 ça enlève
toute idée de
de sacrifier le pion aux quatre en 3
d'une façon ou d'une autre et la menace
en d6 existe donc la cavale et c3 bon je
me moque de la menace en d6 parce que
moi aussi j'ai une menace en dire tout
la partie blanc et tour des huit voies
la tournée protège la caisse des six
tout simplement très simple hélas le
blanc se décide à prendre
le kaiser pu faire un coup avant ils le
font maintenant tout reprend puis on
prend dans prend voilà ils savent ce
qu'ils auraient perdu perdu ne tiendra
pas on n'y a pas moyen de se protéger
longtemps si on joue dame g6 pour voir
le monde dames ces deux suffit à les
prendre
est-ce que khalid sekkat qui empêche le
fou de jouer on joue dame ces deux fous
près on va venir
voilà hélas le les blancs sont toujours
bien il voit là également les noirs en
la paire de foule et bien aussi donc ça
c'est un problème ya la qualité les
bardes option de plus pour la qualité ça
suffit largement
les biens sont contents de d'éliminer du
matériel et de se rapprocher d'une
finale qui pourra être à leur avantage
voire vent nul ça leur suffit puisque
pour gagner le match
donc la marijuana est bien c'est 5 voilà
un contre attaque au centre très bon on
élimine en plus un pion potentiellement
faible puisque si ce pion tombe après le
foot va taper sur ses six bons donc là
ça oblige presque à la prise ou prend 1
en activant les pièces fou prend aux 4
les blancs sont bien y'a pas de problème
mais la position reste tendue voilà
dames 7
eh bien on pas davantage le net quoi
fout un peu 5
attention
tous rêvent cette surprotège attention
il pouvait y avoir des menaces de prison
est certain dans certaines variantes
puisqu'à la fin le fou csn pouvait être
en prise à lecavalier l'ain mais ce que
ali pouvait bouger avec des possibilités
touré fin tout simplement
mais prévient le doublement des tours
qui attaquent f2 alors marc idoux quand
même les tours voilà
mais oui c'est bien parce qu'on voit
bien que il peut y avoir des
possibilités et tôt ou tard de tout
reprend m 2 avec le fou qui quand même
quelque part vise le roi derrière donc
avait dit clouage possible bon pour
l'instant ça tient met en place les
pièces en prévision 2 voilà on met la
pression maximale espérant une faute
vous des quatre sa bouche toute
tentative et sa bise à 7 un petit peu
aussi fo prend d'en prendre position
toujours équilibré structure d'options
quand même à l'avantagé des blancs mais
les noms la qualité et donc la position
reste déséquilibrée donc des
possibilités encore pour les noirs de
l'emporter donc pour marie de revenir au
score
dams et set où j'ai 2 tours 17 attaques
la dame la main quatre fous prend puis
on prend décide d'éliminer sacré un pion
faible elle peut essayer de kobe e5 on
met le pion en 5 de la couleur opposée à
celle du fou à 6 les blancs eux mêmes
mettre leurs pions sur case du fou
puisque l'on pourra le protéger par fou
bessette tour d2 pression maximale ici
sur une deux intentions
j'ai deux triplés dans ce cas là le pion
et 2 serait vraiment emprise dans
bessette les blancs propose carrément un
échange de dames
mais il refuse dame c5 attention
probablement déjà piège parce que
imaginons que les blancs jouent un coup
comme h4 on peut envisager
bon ça marche pas je pense mais on peut
quand même envisager tout reprend f2
avec l'idée t3f 2 dames 33 et la tour
est cloué mais ça marche pas tout
simplement parce que la dame pour revenu
en b2 par exemple on peut aussi jouer
fouet f3 qui bouche la colonne de de la
tour des dames et deux marches aussi
sans doute fait d'un bep de marche avec
la vingtaine donc ça marche pas mais bon
ça fait quand même c'est des petites
idées qui peuvent faire peur
surtout qu'on est en on est en fin de
partie rapide ici on a dépassé les 40e
coup il reste une minute aux deux
joueuses il faut le savoir puisqu'il ya
que dix secondes parcourant plus donc
quand on associe peu de temps on peut
réfléchir mais on risque dans ce cas là
se retrouver qu'une pendules à zéro
donc dès que ça commence à être menaçant
ça fait peur donc dans b5 les blancs qui
propose un échange à noter que jusqu'à
présent depuis le début de partie les
blancs n'ont fait aucune faute aucune
faute je dirais grave un rien marina n'a
rien pu essayer de n'a pas pu profiter
d'aucune précision d'un prend puis on
prend tourbe et de attaque le pion
pouces et 6 protège voilà alors ça a
l'air pénible mais il ya la qualité et
donc la qualité c'est quand même pas
rien voilà j'ai six très bien on va
activer le roi sait ce qu'il faut faire
alors une première une précision des
blancs la f4
de la part de pogo nina bon on élimine
certes on va éliminer un pion mais c'est
un pion isolés contre une chaîne de
pions solide mais bon et en plus on on
laisse la tour la contrôler la seconde
avec un roi qui va être coupée bon on se
couche le trouve pas terrible
puis on prend f 4g prend f4 bon ça
semble quand même difficile pour les
premiers blancs pour les noirs par
contre deux décident emporté à noter
attention que la touriste il doit rester
sur la colonne b parce que si la tour
samba b6 puis on prend et quasiment
forcé à sept et on fera à 8 dames en
récupérant la qualité est sans doute
avec une partie nulle
à la clé une finale deux tours égalité
de pionsat sera mieux donc attention à
la tour doit empêcher b6 la sueur b6
empreinte de la tour
c'est pour ça qu'il faut regarder elle
est magnifiquement placé sept tours là
parce que à la fois donc elle contrôle
la seconde et elle empêche le pion
avancé il faut pas la bouger en tout cas
pas pour le monde autour des 8 marie
actifs ces pièces au maximum elle voue
sa chance à fond
tous rêvent 2 de la parade et blanc ça a
l'air très bon c'est très bien tomber 3
c'est ce qu'on a dit on reste sur la
colonne des taux aux deux les blancs
protège g7 wife 2 non non non selon moi
ça y est les blancs riches à s'activer
autour des détroits pourquoi pas
menaces possibles fouet 4
tours en c3
il faut c'est 6
royal 6 leroy s'active et bunge ou h 4
pourquoi pas
roy au cices
3 3 je rappelle que là on est quasi
blitz donc on va pas commenter beaucoup
sauf sur une grosse erreur tour à 3
alors 3 3 mais nancy b 6
je peux prendre avec le pion puisque la
tour empêche le pion à d'avancé 1 wife 2
3 des 6 commence à avoir un petit oeil
sur le pied sur le fou la tour d2 échec
bon pourquoi pas 3 ces cinq tours des
cinq échecs passés 4 dont des quatre
échecs passés cinq tours des cinq échecs
en espérant de répéter les coups puisque
les blancs veulent annuler en tout cas
se satisfont du nul en tout cas roye b 6
tour 5 voilà on protège le pion mais
mieux que ce canton était emmené
puisqu'on est devant c'est un peu plus
actif mais marié en fait tu as intérêt à
ce que les blancs essaye de passer de
l'autre côté parce que l'ours la seule
chance pour les noirs c'est que les
blancs en attaquant l'autre côté oubli
des trucs de du côté roy et pour essayer
de gagner puisqu'ils et noir doivent
essayer de gagner h6 pourquoi pas il des
idées ou peut-être tenter les noirs de
jouer de jouer tour au 6 mai qui a l'air
bon quand même trop si ce sont là les
blancs jouent tours 7
alors c'est intéressant parce que échec
aura bouge je prends à s'être j'ai deux
pions passé lié au noir joue roi c5 et
laisse le pion à 7 et un bain le prend
3,7 et ben c'est pas terrible en fait
parce que tout reprend 1,3 maintenant
que la tour a lâché le pion et ce roi
finalement il est face à deux tours qui
peuvent
le mater un escalier savez la fameuse
manoeuvre tomber trois tours b 2 échecs
roi la torah un math
bon c'est sûr que par contre ça fait
peur les deux pions passés liés l'un ce
que la tour bouge à cette menace à huit
bons mets et les maths ça va plus vite
que de faire dame donc là c'est chaud
tour 17
marié ce qu'elle voulait une position où
la moindre faute maintenant on peut
faire basculer la partie
tourbes et trois gardes à la fois un
oeil sur l'avancée des pions parce que
ça empêche le pion but d'avancé bon le
roi et déjà ce signe est aussi menace
des possibilités de d'escalier là encore
la faune tour des deux très bien robbie
6 très bien avec le roi mais n'empêche
les pions d'avancé donc ça libère les
tours les tours vont pouvoir se libérer
et pourquoi pas les magies ses deux
pions sinon on va manger ses deux pions
deux pions contre deux pions passé lié
passé lié mais y'a de qualité en plus il
suffirait presque que j'échange une tour
et je pense que ces gagnants roger 2
donc il ya des chances mais les blancs
sont toujours mieux ici 3g 2 c'est pas
terrible terrible tour j'ai trois échecs
bref deux tours h3 attention entourage
trois menaces d pourquoi pas détourage
deux échecs au bij leroy aller où on a
eu 1 dans ce cas là mais si on va en
vain
je peux faire échec la tour descend je
prends roi prend et a pris le peuple et
deux pions et la partie est gagnée parce
que là j'ai vraiment la qualité net en
plus avec deux pions pas s'allier pour
moi contre 2 lié en face les noirs sont
gagnants donc attention ça y est la
marie à ce qu'elle voulait c'est chaud
roy chez deux tours prend h4
tous rêvent deux très bien sans doute il
faut pas le laisser les noirs prendre
dernier pion mais là je pense que marié
réussi ce qu'elle voulait les blancs
s'en aller chercher le petit pion là bas
ils ont sous-estimé le fait qu'il valait
mieux qu'ils défendent leurs droits et
laisser les noirs
ne pas trouver de solutions quasiment
tous que j'ai quatre échecs de 3,4 le
bref comment il fait pour se protéger ça
a l'air chaud salaires perdus ce pion
est perdu et on l'a dit si on arrive à
prendre le dernier pion ça risque d'être
gagnant pour les noirs les grandes
chances que sa une pour les noirs voient
même si ces gagnants
alors là pour nina se dit bah c'est pas
grave je jouais f5 et wii est simple
parce que en cas de prise bien je peux
prendre il n'y a pas de matelas les deux
tours sont mal placés et oui et là marie
rate le guen car il ne voit pas ici
malheureusement alors on est en fait
notre avis un coup gagnant ici
extraordinaire falloir tout rejet 5
pourquoi sa menace maths et oui le
fameux coureur va alors sur la bande et
oui ça menace mat sur la bande sur le
ici sur le couloir et malheureusement le
voit pas bon c'est aller quasiment vide
c'est normal
là les blancs peuvent se défendre le
seul coup sans doute c'est de jouer
voyage 3 mais maintenant simplement
tourcoing f5 et on y est on peut se
regarder on a le fameux roi koupéla vous
savez et bombay les blancs ne monte pas
pouvoir
tout faire c'est qu'ils peuvent pas à la
fois défendre leurs pions là et contenir
les noirs qui ont qui vont avoir des
pions passé bon ils seront pas liées
parce qu'on va sans doute prendre un f5
si on prend m5 ici simplement donc les
noirs reprennent et c'est aux blancs de
jouer voilà pour les blancs si les
blancs ont pas beaucoup de coups
intéressants il faut jouer des coudes
attentes peut-être par exemple pour moi
j'ai trois maine-et-loire peuvent
avancer leurs pions comme ça
exemple ici pour attaquer le pion est à
noter aussi que faut pas oublier que les
finales non je veux dire des bêtises
si je crois qu'il ya certaines finale
retour contre fout qu'ils peuvent gagner
pas beaucoup mais il y en a donc bon ça
peut faire nul mais c'est pas facile à
défendre il faut faire attention
donc en plus dans les glaces et de
possibilités mais en blond là c'est même
pas l'heure puisque j'ai en plus des
pions donc là on peut jouer je sais pas
peut-être en plus on n'a pas peur que de
vous prendre ce qu'on prendrait très
certainement b5
je sais pas
on peut jouer par exemple l'échec roi h3
ici g7 pourquoi pas ce qu'il veut à la
fois entre otages à 7 pourquoi pas mais
surtout on a coupé le roi donc le pion
est marrant c'est donc par exemple ici
si les blancs jouent à cette je prends
du roi très certainement
et si on va prendre le pion qui est
possible ça gagne magnifique toile cette
voie là le fou est floue et que font les
blancs c'est aux blancs de jouer si vous
jouez les pions les prendre et là il
faut donc jouer voilà bon mais la f4
terminé parce qu'au prochain coup je
vais prendre le fou reprend et le pion
fils adam et ses deux pions sont
maîtrisées par laurent voyez ça va vite
donc f5 malheureusement tour g5 n'ai pas
vu par marie c'est dommage parce qu'elle
aurait pu égaliser ici dans cette
position est là donc elle joue j'ai 5 g
c'est bon j'ai cinq gardes des chances 1
c'est encore bon pour le noir il ya deux
pions ollier un les tours quand ils sont
dangereuses ou contre le roi blanc et
puis là les blancs shufu 17 simplement
tout f4 propose un échange et blanc né
change pas mes joues tour ces deux
pour ces quatre on empêche la tour quand
même là attention parce que depuis ont
passé lié à ça peut être très vite
pénible tour à 2 3 4 pour ces deux tours
fc 4 2 pour ces 3 pourquoi pas pas
forcément le meilleur
on rappelle qu'on est en lice tous ces
six tours f 4 1 3 2
tours fc4 toi
pour ces deux échecs moi j'ai 30 ans de
ses trois échecs
bref deux tours f4 un échec deux tours b
4 on veut faire ici sans doute doublette
3d 2 et là je sais pas ce qui m'arrive
trompe pas elle vous tous rage 3 est
alors le problème de h3c que cissé lot
si cette tour fait échec on n'a pas de
match à cause du fou alors les là ici
les blancs jouent maintenant à 7 assez
lent donc les échecs sont finis a pas de
maths
après tours b 2 échecs simplement roi c1
et je peux pas jouer tous rêvent 2 qui
menacerait maths c'est non la toile ma
place ici la tour était en g3 tour f2
menace maths et si on fait d'amener au
risque se faire mater donc
c'était une possibilité sans doute une
heure à une astuce que vous voulez jouer
mari mais ça marche pas ça ne marche pas
donc
ici après ton f2 simplement abandon les
noirs se rendent compte que
ça marche pas à cause du fou donc dames
et c'est terminé mais c'est terminé il
n'y a pas de made donc ça va
ça va être même gagnant donc pour les
blancs donc malheureusement ici marine
arrive pas elle rate
après 5 elle rate le gain tout cas
d'excellentes chances de gain pour pas
dire gains tour g5 qui menace et à mater
qui prenait le pion le dernier pion des
blancs de ce côté là et qui permettait
au noir d'envisager une victoire
possible et donc un retour dans le match
et non c'est pas possible
maintenant elle est battue 2-0 au tie
break
donc c'est terminé elle n'est pas
qualifiée pour pour les quarts de finale
de ce championnat du monde 2015 alors
qui est qualifié on va retrouver koné
roux qui jouera contre la vainqueure
celle qui a gagné contre stephano va
museler chouk voilà donc on verra ça
plus tard et puis ans inonde autres
matches il y à arabiser qui va jouer
face à arica alors arica c'est une
indienne et à labatut kosteniuk voilà
elle a battu kosteniuk au tie break
obtenues qui était revenu au score
un partout mais elle a perdu le tie
break donc arica surprise de ce tournoi
qui élimine l'ex champion du monde
kosteniuk une indienne qui semble très
très forte qui a du talent alors pogo
nina donc viennent de battre marie sebag
et le jouera contre la dernière chinoise
souza au la dernière chinoise en lice
sur les sept ou huit qui avaient au
départ et donc ça va être un match
extrêmement intéressant parce que pour
une idée à montrer quand même qu'elle
faisait très très peu de fautes
un jouet très très bien de l'ouverture
et y compris fin de jeu est fini final à
part l'erreur dans la première partie
face à marie finalement elle a très bien
joué les finales aussi donc ça va être
un match tendu
zaho et sans doute quand même favorite 1
puisque
nello au maximum assez assez élevé 1 pas
loin de 2580 et enfin dernier quart de
finale très intéressant aussi
il sera entre musique zouk et pia
gravelines garbia gramling la suédoise n
qui est une grande expérimentées du
circuit féminin depuis longtemps et même
du circuit international tout court
voilà qui est très très connu et qui
fait partie de la légende du jeu
d'échecs désormais depuis accra mine
toujours toujours là dans les grands
rendez vous voilà donc des cars finale
quand même très intéressant avec on le
voit les favoris téléstar kosteniuk et
stéphane aubin qui se sont fait donc
éliminé et marie sebag ici donc de peu
qu'il est mais qui peut-être manqué de
fraîcheur sur la fin on voit sans doute
manque de préparation puisqu'elle a
souffert autant beaucoup notamment dans
les ouvertures en sortant d'ouverture
avec des positions souvent un peu
inférieur et donc ça finit par peser et
ça lui permettait pas ça lui a pas
permis malheureusement d'avoir le petit
plus qu'il aurait permis d'aller plus
loin
voilà merci d'avoir suivi sur des bonal
tv et à bientôt pour la suite de ce
championnat du monde féminin 2015 qu'on
va continuer bien sûr à suivre notamment
donc ces quarts de finale et puis
jusqu'à une finale qui s'annonce
passionnante
au revoir